et politiciens corrompus et leurs
intérêts particuliers ont régné sur ce
pays depuis trop longtemps
aujourd'hui c'est notre fête de
l'indépendance ne fait pas d'erreur nos
valeurs fondamentales sont en jeu dans
ce scrutin
les premiers électeurs à se rendre dans
l'isoloir ont été les habitants du petit
état du new hampshire
le résultat est déjà connu il est
symbolique et ne présage en rien de
l'issue du scrutin
c'est hillary clinton qui l'a emporté
face à donald trump les deux candidats
seront à new york pour la soirée
électorale
c'est aussi ici qu'ils ont tous les deux
voté ce matin donald trump aux alentours
de 11h hillary clinton
un petit peu plus tôt vers 8h30
l'arithmétique des minorités devrait lui
donner la victoire mais c'est pas tout à
fait sûr parce que elle a quand même
fait beaucoup de gens là des tests d'un
mec et franchement tout ce qu'ils
voulaient de l'est les âneries la
brutalité tous que ce type peut sortir
et quand même invraisemblable
donc je voterai quand même pour hillary
clinton mais met en effet tout ce
qu'elle représente mais assez détestable
jon super nerveux mais plutôt
enthousiaste c'est une immense
opportunité à quelques minutes près il
n'aura pas vu ses militantes féministes
seins nus floutés par la télé américaine
elles sont venues dans le bureau de vote
du candidat républicain dénoncé sa
misogynie la liste des des promesses et
des malédictions d'ailleurs de donald
trump les justes considérable des
malédictions pour vous ce sera une
malédiction s'il était élu demain à
écouter ça poserait un abord cela nous
poserait un problème majeur à nous
européens par les états unis la france
et d'une longue histoire rien entre nous
le lien du sang des jeunes américains
sont morts pour notre liberté
jamais on peut l'oublier je fais
confiance au peuple américain pour
savoir quel est le choix qui correspond
le mieux
aux valeurs aux principes à la liberté à
cette relation avec la france est avec
l'europe
françois hollande le président de la
république a regardé le début de la
soirée électorale à paris et maintenant
il est allé se coucher il dort mais un
de ses plus proches conseillers doit le
réveiller par téléphone dès que les
résultats de l'élection américaine sont
connus alors que moi j'étais hier à
philadelphie avec les familles obama et
les familles clinton parce qu'il y avait
barack et michelle obama et hillary et
bill clinton et même chelsea clinton et
on avait franchement l'impression que
c'était bon ça y est on a gagné on peut
se le dire bravo
bienvenue dans le club il arrive donc il
est allé se coucher en pensant que
hillary clinton allait gagner largement
eh ben pour l'instant visiblement c'est
pas le cas donc il risque d'avoir une
surprise en se réveillant hillary
clinton est donné vainqueur dans
virginie et dans le colorado ça fait 22
grands électeurs pour ces deux états
donc c'est important car vous êtes
attendre et pour l'instant c'est plutôt
il tombe dans l'escarcelle de donald
trump
effectivement et le dernier en date
c'est donc le ai'a et l'ohio l'un de ces
états clés qu'on attendait avec
énormément d'impatience car il a du
poids regardez ce qu'a twitté tout à
l'heure hillary clinton
quels que soient les choix quel que soit
le scénario de ce soit merci pour tout
ça sent pas bon la victoire quand même
quand on fait des adieux
c'est un séisme ce matin que nous vivons
donald trump est au seuil de la maison
blanche